alors olive olive toi tu comprends pas
qu'ils aient des quartiers privilégiés
en prison mais carrément pas mais je
pense qu'on prend un peu le problème à
l'envers d'ailleurs et si on vous
reprenez le problème je pense qu'à des
pancartes qu'ils finiraient par se
tourner quel des gens qu'ils soient
isolés parce que c'est des politiques ou
ceci cela à la rigueur ça je pense que
ça peut se comprendre par contre quand
on voit l'état des cellules 9 mètres
carrés je pense qu'il a les mêmes en
formulant les chambres d'hôtel ils sont
belles à la fois et c'est vrai on est
honnête ça c'est ça c'est complètement
inadmissible parce que ça s'appelle de
la discrimination quand tu as fait
quelque chose et tu finis en prison tout
le monde doit être jugé pareil et tout
le monde doit être condamnée pareil
qu'ils soient isolés à la rigueur je
pourrais le comprendre mais pas de pas
dans ce genre de cellules qui après il
ya un autre problème en fait très
honnêtement moi je t'écoute parler
depuis tout à l'heure et j'ai vu depuis
une semaine et puis les reportages sur
netflix machin bidule où tu fais un
petit peu le clown
ça fait
quelque chose à à tous les citoyens et
je pense que ça c'est dramatique par
rapport à ce que tu as fait tu vois
quand tu dis j'arrive en prison avec une
limousine et machin ou bidule par
rapport à ce que tu as fait quand tu
quand tu voles l'état 280 millions
d'euros tu as volé tous les français
parce que l'état en fait il n'a pas
d'argent à l'état c'est nos impôts qui
remplit sont les caisses d'état et quand
je vois des gens qui arrivent à sourire
parce que tu fais le clown sur les
plateaux télé et qu'on entraîne peu
médiatisé aujourd'hui et presse que tu
vas finir en héros moi sincèrement ça me
retourne le ventre parce que il faut que
tous les citoyens soient conscients que
tu as pris de l'argent dans les poches
de tout le monde en fait par rapport à
ce que tu as fait et ça je trouve ça
inadmissible sincèrement
les talents baïla in a page et sa haine
aussi oui mais je me sens un peu perdue
alors va-t-on 33 là chez georges ans que
je fais de la star sait même pas de quoi
tu parles
quand les blues in elle avait tout
d'abord au quand tu vois la télé voilà
réellement la limousine c'est une cinéma
est ce que moi je venais rang diminue
avec médiatique avec mes impôts tue
parce que c'est de l'argent que tu as
volé il a quand même payer que mais
c'est différent c'est que toi la seule
différence c'est que toi tu va [ __ ] le
bordel dehors dans la rue pour arrêter
les gens de travailler les ferrari n'ont
jamais sifflé c'est une drogue et elle
sait pas aller au départ les alors
laisser parler aux jeunes
espoirs pars-lès-chavanges mrd tu te
prends pas avec moi laisse moi parler je
te le dis ce qui laisse moi pas mais
t'es qui toi et toi t'étais qui toi il
sort de prison
mais alors affiner ses marques
à laisser aller à l'essai pour défendre
les malais haut niveau les volets aulas
il n'y a pas répondu à la serre comme
mélenchon tu as pas les gens parler en
criant cris en criant allez allez y sont
la seule différence avec quoi on sait qu
il va l'argent des genres il admis dans
les beaux quartiers est il des projets
vitaux alors gbagbo défend restons sur
le sujet la leçon sur le sujet alors
marco que c'est à dire des choses que je
vais te dire moi ce que j'ai fait je
l'assumé moi j'aime tout ce qui est beau
la seule différence c'est que je veux
pas les criées j'ai faim dehors je me
suis servi j'ai jamais dis et je me suis
servi ces distributions peux comprendre
que ça me dérange que tu te serves dans
la poche des français d'accord mais
pourquoi pourquoi les politiques vont
quoi mais attention je dîne avec des
contrats des choses que je
mets dans la même classe que en fait
d'accord ces gentilles c'est pas mal
parce que je voulais faire la politique
il ya une chose que je vais te dire
commentaires c'est pas mal parce que je
t'explique avec zone la politique qui
sont un peu comme moi ils inventent
n'importe quoi pour être élus doivent
tendre à l'avantagé c'est je crois en
dieu dieu m'a mis dans la lumière du ska
quand je sais pas mais la différence
j'ai envie d'y être parce que c'est
tellement beau tu vois dit fière de mon
côté non pas du tien